let's start with number one increasing
and you think increasingly unsustainable
levels of debt so the first one as
you're pointing out the large production
of debt and debt monetization
um is an area that I specialize in and
in terms of understanding as a macro
Global macro investor and that produces
what we're seeing in a mechanical way
which means that the value of money uh
goes down in other words you could look
at it very simply that if the quantity
of money and credit which is buying
power
increases faster than the quantity of
goods and services and financial assets
that the prices of good services and
financial assets will rise the value of
money will go down and so we see that
happening now we're in the part of the
cycle go for that in which everybody
received a lot of checks and all that
money coming in and people's paper net
worth then went up because he got more
money but and we're not used to
inflation but what is happening is then
you're in that part of the cycle where
there's that inflation pressure and good
services and financial assets and what
that has to do is then cause reactions
and those reactions are along the lines
like people no longer will want to hold
cash
Investments they will not want to hold
Bond Investments because those will
start to have a negative real return and
as that inflation psychology and that
investment psychology changes it changes
the movement of money so it worsens the
supply demand picture for a month for
the for money so you see you are seeing
the beginning of a supply demand
imbalance